the great streamer wars of 2019 have
officially begun courage has signed an
exclusive deal to stream on YouTube and
with shroud and ninja already making the
jump toon mixer the world's wealthiest
people are fighting over our favorite
streamers this is only going to get wild
[Music]
the conversation in the streaming and
gaming world has been dominated by these
moves over the last few months first of
course you had ninja who blew
everybody's mind when he announced he
was going to mix her full time a few
months back as of today I will be
streaming exclusively on mixer mixer is
of course Microsoft streaming platform
and people were estimating like 10
million dollars per year for this
contract but then twitch clap back they
signed it NIC mercs to a multi year
streaming view and to me that was a
really significant move because it
showed that twitch was willing to go to
bat and try to keep some of these
massive creators on twitch and then
recently we had shroud he took off and
went to mixer just like ninja and like I
said in that video a trend had begun hey
Mike
yeah what should do you it I make a move
and you oh hi busy and after that
everybody wanted to know who was the
next streamer that was gonna leave
twitch and yesterday we got our answer
when courage signed an exclusive deal
with YouTube gaming I'm leaving what why
this may come as a shock to you guys but
honestly when I first started this I had
no idea how big the creators become so
when are you leave in hundred thieves
what I'm not leaving hundred thieves I'm
joining you too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and with the move obviously there's a
new horse in the race it's not just
Microsoft and Amazon who owns twitch
it's also Google who owns YouTube okay
so I'm starting to feel like this sort
of thing happens every week and new guys
leaving but why is this happened well I
think like you and me have for years a
lot of these massive tech companies and
some of the wealthiest people in the
world have decided that these guys that
are bringing in all these tens of
thousands of views they've got a lot of
value they can make you a lot of money
and so after Microsoft and mixer Wenonah
got ninja a sort of rat race begin it's
kind of like him every player in the NBA
just was a free agent all at once and
all of the teams got to bid to get the
best players on their squad imagine if
tomorrow every team in the NBA had a
shot at LeBron James it would be chaos
so it's the same thing here ninja Shroud
Nick Marx none of these guys were
exclusively signed to twitch which means
everybody had a shot and once they
notice that that was a shot they wanted
to take things started to pick up
quickly it's obvious why any NBA team
would want to go ahead and get LeBron
James and it's the same thing here
twitch is a huge platform and right now
they're the only place you go to watch
live streams so mixer and YouTube have
decided to go out and get the biggest
names on twitch to try to bring some of
that attention to their platform because
they think they get these guys they can
keep up with twitch and maybe if they do
it right they can get even bigger than
twitch all right so why courage
well since Fortnite took over the
Internet and it's all we can see on our
timelines on Twitter every day courage
has become massive he's one of those
guys with more than 2 million followers
on twitch and usually strings to more
than 10k viewers and of course since he
saw him with a hundred thieves he's made
YouTube a massive part of what he does
he's even got ariana grande tweeting
about
I'm good I'm good
another thing about signing courage is
that like shroud to me he doesn't seem
really tied to any game this is like an
OG eSports guy I mean he was a caster in
Call of Duty forever he's also a pretty
family-friendly streamer which if you
haven't noticed all these guys signed
these contracts are pretty
family-friendly all right so another
shot fired in the stream work courage is
gone and of course everybody online was
talking about it yesterday Jack is no
longer on twitch is now a YouTube
content creator full sent he really
mixed it up didn't teach at at this
point it's like calm in place one of
these things happens all the time
and afterwards it sets twitch and
twitter a buzz for multiple dates Jack I
just wanted to say I'm super proud of
you congratulations and I know you're
gonna absolutely good I need you bro
love you man all right so here's the
part of the video where I break down
what this could actually mean and try to
hypothesize where we're going next with
this stuff like I've said in the past
these moves to me are a net positive I
think competition in this world is a
good thing and it gives people who have
been paid more or less in twitch subs
and donations for the past 10 years an
actual salary but to me the big thing to
focus on what this move is that somehow
an actual war has started over the
streamers does the wall come in Ned I
don't know when I don't know who will be
fighting that he's come in we've done a
lot of speculating in the office over
the last few months ever since mixer
sign ninja that obviously now there's
pressure for every big streamer to get
signed like I said but this time another
massive company has jumped into the ring
and so now I think it's pretty safe to
say that your favorite streamer whether
it's tea food or pokey vane or Tim the
tap man is having conversations with
mold
company's about signing exclusives this
is not the end of this at all it's gonna
happen constantly over the next year and
I personally can't wait to find out
where everybody lands and now if YouTube
store in their name in the ring who's
next in terms of big companies the three
companies that have started this war now
YouTube twitch and mixer they're endemic
to gaming but what happens when like
[ __ ] Facebook tries to sign T food to
a deal or something that's it would be
crazy but it's more likely than you
think this war has only gotten started
and it is only gonna get Wilder one
thing one thing I'm I want to know is
when when it when is twitch gonna gonna
sign celebrities like we're we're
talking we're talking about all this
stuff like oh t foo and ninja they're
celebrities so they deserve contracts
too yeah yeah but one is when does Drake
get his twitch contract or whatever you
know